Caster: "This is when bengi has to step up to save SKT"
Caster: "On blue side, remember with bengi in they do not have a Nidalee player. You cannot give Peanut Nidalee.
We talked about how you need adaptation and now you're forced to ban Nidalee on Blue side.
This could be the last game of the night or if bengi has anything to say, we go to a game five."
Already a two-time World Champion, Bengi was
supposedly over the hill.
But Bengi was a World Champion.
And with everything on the line, SKT needed
a win.
A veteran voice to show them the path to victory. They
needed Bengi.
After all, they’ve never won Worlds without him.
This is Bengi’s story
Bae “Bengi” Seong-woong was born on November 21, 1994 and not much is known about his life
before League of Legends.
Bengi’s first recorded games were on an
amateur team called BBT, which played in a
Korean secondary league known as NLB.
On that team, he played alongside legendary
support player Cho “Mata” Se-hyeong.
(Casting)
After the team disbanded, bengi ended up at
a tryout for SK Telecom’s new sister team,
SK Telecom T1 K.
And though he left midway because he felt
he wasn’t good enough to make the team,
coach Kim “kkOma” Jeong-gyun saw something
great in the young jungler and managed to
pull him back. SKT was built around a young
solo queue star that was turning heads at
the time, Lee “Faker” Sang-hyeok.
(Casting)
The team was designed to be aggressive, capitalizing
on Faker’s playstyle.
It worked.
(Casting)
SKT’s sister team placed third in Champions
Spring, and posted impressive results in their
debut season.
But more importantly, they had the potential
to be great .
MonteCristo: "All aboard the Korean hype train, SK Telecom T1."
The team went 12-4 in the summer season and
qualified for Worlds 2013 where they swept
Royal Club in the Grand Finals to take home
their first world championship.
(Casting)
SKT returned home to Korea as champions, and
they didn’t slow down for even a second.
(Casting)
SKT won Champions Winter with a perfect record and were
without a doubt the best team in the world.
But amidst all the success, few noticed Bengi’s
playstyle slowly shifting.
His early game aggression, a hallmark of SKT’s
fast-paced bulldozer playstyle, gave way to
something more supportive.
Bengi was Faker’s invisible guardian.
He was the man who set up Faker for the flashy
plays that have made him legendary.
There’s no question that Faker was the best,
but he couldn’t have done it without Bengi.
After Champions Winter, SKT started to crumble.
They placed fourth in Champions Spring, and
were then swept in a tiebreaker match against
Samsung White which forced them to play in
the Regional Finals, where they would eventually
lose to NaJin White Shield 3-1.
(Casting)
Just a few months prior, SKT were the reigning
World Champions with a perfect record in their
home region.
But they couldn’t keep up.
Bengi wasn’t solely blamed for the team’s
struggles, but the common perception was that
Faker, the greatest player on earth, just
couldn’t carry his entire team.
SKT rebuilt in the offseason, shedding everyone
except for Faker and Bengi.
The god and his right hand man.
But even so, people were ready to write off
Bengi.
He was part of a roster that not even Faker
could carry, and his mechanics were seen as
being out of date.
Younger players were faster, more adaptable,
and had deeper champion pools.
(Casting)
In 2015, SKT
signed Im “T0M” Jae-hyeon as a substitute
for Bengi, and swapped between the two junglers
throughout the season.
What was telling though, was the fact that
SKT elected to play Bengi for all three games
of their finals series against the GE Tigers.
A series SKT went on to win 3-0.
(Casting)
In interviews, Bengi said that watching T0M
play helped him regain his confidence after
his abysmal 2014 season.
That’s right.
Bengi, the guy who walked out of tryouts only
to be pulled back in, needed a rookie to remind
himself how good he could be.
SKT went on to win the summer season, punching
their ticket to Worlds in the process.
Fortunately for Bengi, SKT took mid lane substitute,
Lee "Easyhoon" Ji-hoon to the tournament,
meaning that Bengi was the only jungler the
team would field at Worlds.
SKT went on to win the tournament, giving
Faker and Bengi their second world championship
in three years.
(Casting)
But even with a second world championship under
his belt, people still kept harping on Bengi.
Ahead of the Spring 2016 season, SKT signed
Kang "Blank" Sun-gu, and started him for most
of the regular season.
Bengi only played in 17 of SKT’s 41 games
in the spring, and rode the bench throughout
the playoffs.
Caster: "I wish I could have been watching their scrims. Watching them decide between Blank and Bengi
because from what we've seen both of them have been pretty poor."
SKT started Bengi more often in the summer, but
as the season wore on, Bengi lost more and
more and was benched after just 14 games.
Again, Blank played in the playoffs instead
of Bengi.
Caster: "Blank, the one thing you can say about him, has stepped up when he's needed to. You think back to LCK final you think back to MSI final.
He was good in those series and he's gonna need to be good today"
SKT took Bengi with them to Worlds in 2016,
but he only played in two games during the
group stage.
SKT started Bengi against Royal in the quarterfinals,
but after losing Game 1, quickly subbed him
out for Blank.
Jatt: "I like the substitution for them. I think Blank has been their go-to for the majority of the season and I was surprised whenever we would see Bengi.
If they weren't going to make it a permanent thing I thought it was because of his world championship experience.
But this SKT team has won the IEM World Championship with Blank, they won MSI with Blank and I think if they want to win they should be doing it with Blank."
The writing seemed to be on the wall for Bengi:
he was still good, but no longer great.
But in Game 4 of the semifinals, SKT were
on the ropes.
Jatt: "SKT have to change things up in this next one because they tried round two of the Miss Fortune lane,
they lost again. They have to change."
And with everything on the line, SKT needed a win.
That's when they called in Bengi
(Casting)
Bengi started in four of SKT’s Grand Final games
against Samsung Galaxy, going 3-1 and notching
his and Faker’s third World Championship
in five year, cementing SKT’s legacy
as League of Legends’ first dynasty.
(Casting)
Surely the entire world would finally see
that when Bengi is sitting next to Faker,
no team in the world could stop them.
But Bengi is always doomed to be the bridesmaid,
and never the bride.
He’s invisible and most importantly he's not Faker.
SKT dropped bengi in 2017 and replaced him
with the Tigers’ star jungler Han “Peanut”
Wang-ho.
Bengi went off to Vici Gaming in China, where
he ended up losing a relegation match and
being dropped from that team too.
(Casting)
SKT had a strong 2017, placing first in the
Spring Playoffs and second in the summer,
but they didn’t look dominant going into
Worlds.
(Casting)
SKT placed second at Worlds in 2017, which
marked their first ever loss in a Worlds Grand
Finals series.
Their first time playing at the tournament
without Bengi.
YamatoCannon: "It's insane what they did, knowing that they've won three world championships, expecting to win four is natural because of
the dominant streak that they've had, but in all seriousness what they've accomplished, no one is going to come close to this
or sure something is quite close to this with the two victories but in theory it's still incredible what they did.
And maybe it takes one year, maybe it takes two years for them to come back to that same form, but kkOma knows the recipe to success.
SKT knows the recipe for success within League."
It’s impossible to say exactly how much
bengi impacted SKT’s playstyle, and whether
or not he completely altered the way SKT treats
junglers moving forwards.
But he’s returned to SKT, this time as a coach. Bengi and Faker have
been reunited.
While Bengi is playing an even more supportive,
invisible role this time around, one thing
will always remain true: when the unkillable
demon king has bengi by his side, nothing
can stop SKT.